[Music]
kendall jenner strips down to her
birthday suit and gets candid about life
in the spotlight it was just kind of an
emotional thing for me the 26 year old
model slays on the cover of id magazine
spring cover and inside she's bearing
all
literally
yep that's the reality star casually
posing in the buff with some
strategically placed shadows it's
honestly really fun kendall also serves
up some poolside hotness and goes blonde
for the mag
the picks come alongside an equally
eye-opening interview the model gets
real about growing up famous quote i
used to be really angry you could find
old videos of me screaming at the
paparazzi for no reason but also for a
very obvious reason i'm a lot more at
peace with things now i'm just enjoying
the ride of course kendall's famous
family's reality show keeping up with
the kardashians premiered in 2007 when
kenny was just 11 years old
[Music]
it's really awesome i mean not a lot of
people can say that they work with their
family every single day we have the show
together so
it's um it's a blessing it's really cool
and keeping up cameras were rolling when
kendall first started modeling yes yes
gorgeous beautiful beautiful wow
wow
when e.t chatted with kendall and her
sister kylie back in 2015 they said
despite their superstar status they're
just like us
i mean we're normal people we go through
our normal like emotional days or like
heart rough days like we're just like
anyone else growing up in front of the
spotlight is
extremely difficult and you're growing
and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but there's so many
blessings that come along with it too so
we're grateful for it not much to
complain about i think having so many
people like love you is such a blessing
i don't know like you wouldn't expect
this many people to like care about you
and want to see you succeed so i think
that that's really awesome and we
definitely really appreciate it
not only has kendall dominated the
fashion world i'm super excited it's a
full dream come true she's found love
with nba star devin booker and she's
building her own empire with a tequila
line longevity is my main goal and
kendall tells the mag she's loving being
in the driver's seat quote i'm a control
freak at heart at a young age i had to
give up that control and let someone
else portray me in the way that they
wanted to that was my job now being on
the other side is taking that control
back in a way building my own brand and
feeling empowered has been really
amazing everything's like so good right
now and i'm very happy and kendall says
life just keeps getting better it still
feels like i'm not fully formed but with
every chapter i become a little bit more
fulfilled
[Music]
you